is there a percentage of of um the
population that has
um like a secure attachment style versus
um a dismissive or an anxious like how
does that break down in society what
you're referring to are attachment
styles and it's been studied uh by this
woman called mary ainsworth and it's
based on john bolby's attachment theory
so this is just the background of people
wondering where they were styles so what
what they did is they are they like me
understand that connection between
mother and child or earliest caregivers
and children are the most pivotal
connections that we can make and when
that connection is not solid then it
shows up in our styles in our patterns
and the more secure that attachment
those early children years are the more
secure we are when we grow up so
in my work i only see the ones who come
in in trouble so for me i'll say hundred
percent are our
insecure attachment
but i i think there's a truth in that
that
you know the reason we're so effed up is
because
we are insecure within and why are we
insecure we're insecure because
somewhere we believe we're not worthy
where did this where did this belief
system come from
they come from only two places number
one from culture
and especially first girls and women
culture has told us over and over again
that there is a way to be a perfect
woman and if you don't follow that way
then you are doomed in a in a way so my
last book i don't know whether you have
it i'd love to send it to you
is this book it's called a radical
awakening it's for women so you should
get that so women especially have been
messed up
with this cultural message that we're
not worthy
and the second place we get this message
from is from our parents and the reason
we get this message from our parents is
because they have this message that
they're not worthy
right so so this is how unworthiness
goes over and beyond oneself so why are
we insecure because we don't believe
we're worthy so
this is what i help parents help their
children with is to to help the parents
enter a sense of worth
and
a strong inner connectivity so that then
they will transmit this radiance to
their children but this requires a lot
of inner work on part of the parent the
parent has to undo their own inner
[ __ ] that they've inherited from
culture they have to undo their own
childhood legacies so i'm asking parents
a tall task
to heal their own inner wounds so that
then they can heal their children
i think one of the hardest things
in my mind is how do you become aware
because seeing yourself seems to be
really one of the biggest hurdles our
life is is the mirror showing us us but
we take it personally we get triggered
we project
where does the awareness come in how do
you actually start to
how can you you know i've watched you
talking about you know narcissism and
like something like that like nobody
goes into a therapist often go so i'm a
narcissist or whatever their issue is no
you don't walk in with that kind of an
awareness and but i i really do feel in
my heart that most people want to be
good and they want a happy life and you
know if there was a way to become aware
of it
what path would you take people down how
would we get more people to become aware
so awareness is not a given and it's not
a gift that your partners or your
friends will come to you with like hey
i'm aware i'm an [ __ ] it has happened
never right
that's why we have relationships because
relationships are where
you get to see the mirror
and especially parenting are you a mom
i'm not no okay you'll see if you ever
choose to be a mom that you will be
given un
unlimited opportunities to see how f'ed
up you are so you'll be very very
grateful and my sister has three girls
and
she the other night she um she put a
headset on and sent me a picture and she
goes i didn't want to kill my kids
tonight so i put the headset on yeah and
it's like she goes nobody nobody was
nobody nobody left last night
everybody's good but the point is she's
like she becomes really aware of like i
get triggered when they do this and you
know children definitely but also
relationships you know i've been through
my fair share of relationships and
there's always a new level of awareness
and you think you're going into the next
one like healed and happy and well and
you bring in your best and then somehow
you find a new level there too yes yes
the relationships
are the place where you get to see the
mirror but you don't have to look right
in the mirror you can look at it you can
look at the issues but you can still
deflect the reflection
so it really depends on the person's
level of truth seeking the person's
level of wanting to create awareness
you know growth is so scary for many
people because it's
taking accountability
for your own wounds
and we just would rather blame other
people it's so much more satisfying and
easy
but eventually there comes a screeching
halt and it's called rock bottom where
you're like oh maybe i'm the common
denominator and that's why with parents
it's i do the work with parents first is
because
you were with your children from the
moment they were born so you gotta look
at you gotta look at yourself and that's
why parenting is so good for humanity in
a way because children bring you to your
knees and you can't blame the
mother-in-law you know you gotta take a
look at yourself when it comes to
parenting so in that aspect
children do us a great favor
and allow us to take accountability but
again like you said it's it's a really
tough nut to to crack because people are
so defensive sometimes i like it's
almost when there's a science to things
because it helps me get past it it's not
some an opinion or something it's just
how things work so what is the operating
system that exists that keeps you in
that
projection mode where you're protecting
yourself
um and you can't see yourself like what
is the loop happening what happens when
you just
you just you choose or you don't even
know how to look at yourself like what's
happening that keeps you in this
projection loop yeah great great
question you know it's so funny using
the word loop because i'm doing this
course in in three weeks and i'm talking
about loops and we get into these these
cycles and we can't break out so the
reason we're stuck in this loop is
because when we get triggered right
there's an external trigger we believe
that the trigger
is because of the external
factor
and then we seek to annihilate the
trigger
and we seek to control fix and manage
the trigger so we try to change the
trigger
the trigger doesn't get changed
keeps triggering us and we keep
believing it's the trigger and we keep
trying to change the trigger so if we
get stuck in this mad loop if your
friend comes late for your birthday
party
and you get pissed
you then seek to
control that behavior in your friend in
some way so you yell you scream you
don't talk to her oh your kid says i
hate you mom
you get pissed you seek to control that
behavior you yell scream punish and
don't talk to your kid or whatever your
partner says hey
honey you know i'm not going to be there
for your whatever your presentation
you get triggered you get pissed you
yell and scream we're just stuck in this
little little very tiny circle called a
dysfunctional loop it's so simple and
primitive that when you realize how
how simplistic we are you'll be shocked
right trigger get angry yell at the
trigger control the trigger end the
trigger next trigger same thing and then
we just keep doing the same loop yeah
what we are missing is many steps in the
loop which we are not seeing
number one
i teach this and this is a profound
message but
what i teach is that there is no trigger
and people are like hello what
of course there's a trigger my children
are designed to trigger me they are they
are honed machines
people are desi the whole world is
designed to trigger me what do you mean
there's no trigger
so that in itself is revolutionary right
and what i say is that there's no
trigger on the inside in on the inside
the only trigger on the outside there's
only a trigger on the inside there is no
trigger on the outside so that in itself
pisses people off and they want to fire
me and they don't want to come to
therapy anymore because we've been
raised to believe that the trigger is on
the outside so i'm delegitimizing their
whole basis for their existence the
existence was like no i'm angry i'm
blaming that person i'm resentful i'm
holding on
because they believe the triggers on the
outside now are there triggers on the
outside yes
for example if you got raped you can't
say that that was on the inside that was
on the outside or if you've got if you
get caught in a hurricane there's a
trigger on the outside yes when it comes
to our physical safety
physical bondage
there is such a thing as a trigger so if
your husband is beating you up please
yes that is not on the inside that's on
the outside i'm talking about emotional
reactivity all of those triggers are on
the inside life is just so nuanced it's
hard to sift through it when you're
trying to do it for yourself in an
emotional state so like how do you
determine the difference between a
trigger and just someone being
disrespectful or someone not respecting
you or your boundaries or you know uh
you as a person like how how what are
what are some ways that we can where we
can figure out it's a trigger versus
something else so you first
understand that
the trigger is not just on the outside
it's
it's on the inside when it's emotional
now you turn inward so the next thing in
the loop instead of fixing controlling
and killing the trigger
is look inward you have to do that next
vital step to go okay how much of this
is me i know it's me also
because i'm getting really reactive
right so my friend came late for the
birthday party that is an event
but it's become a trigger because it's
affecting me on the inside otherwise
it's just an event it's neutral
now you look inward and go why does it
bother me so much that i really don't
want to talk to this person anymore now
you investigate now you deconstruct and
then you may come to the conclusion you
know what because this friend never
shows up on time and i take it as a sign
of disrespect
now you can go to the next step what do
i want to do about it now you make a
choice do i want to never speak to this
person again because i think it's it's
atrocious or can i have a conversation
and maybe it's just different styles
of cultural
you know timeliness
like in india for example where i'm from
it's it's just the culture to not show
up on time it's not disrespectful but
when i came to america
people take it as a sign of disrespect
right so i'm like okay i understand now
i learn i'll negotiate so you have to go
through a process of inquiry and
investigation but why we get stuck in
that loop you talked about is because we
are reactive and we are righteous and we
believe that the trigger is entirely
always external
that mindset has to break if you want to
live a better life and a freer life you
have to
create that pause between trigger right
stimulus and response it's a basic
psychological tool you have to learn
that there are many things happening in
between trigger and response that is
based on our
childhood based on our mindset our
cultural interpretations and if we're
not skilled or don't want to learn how
to be skilled then fine everything will
trigger us no problem be trigger happy
and we are a trigger happy culture
and there is no pause there's no inquiry
and that's why we drink too much and eat
too much because everything is
triggering us look at how many different
things in the world there are with drugs
and drinking and
all kinds of different things even you
can go on the healthy side of things you
can exercise too much you can
you know you can you can go on too many
trips like there's a million ways that
you can avoid the issue what kind of
program could you even go into like
getting into a relationship say you
enter a relationship is there some kind
of like self-auditing that we could do
that would help us enter
with more awareness is there like ground
rules that we should have i mean it's
one thing to have your parents and your
family but it's another thing in a
relationship where you're actively
making a decision to be in it how do you
enter into that with the best of
potential to uh be able to work through
things because the point is is that
relationships i think that in life we're
meant to kind of uncover this stuff
we're meant to grow we're meant to
evolve and relationships give us that
opportunity but they usually end in such
disaster because we just take everything
so personally and we can't deal with it
and we think it's someone else's fault i
don't know i wonder if there's some what
can we do when we enter a relationship
to give us a healthy chance and a
healthy opportunity to be honest and
share and not be offended
yeah i think it's you know
your own inner healing that you've done
on your own path
and then really choosing a person
who you can grow with
but that doesn't mean forever
and posterity but it means that
it's not just blatant dumping and
emotional venting but if there's
opportunity because each person is
working on their own healing so at first
we choose partners just based on
chemical attraction or physical
proximity or you know financial need and
those are the wrong reasons to choose a
partner they can be eventual reasons and
they're good reasons but they're not the
first reasons the first reason to choose
a partner
is a person
that you match with in terms of your
spiritual signature in terms of your
emotional healing and you have to really
put emotional health as a top priority
right after you know the cuteness factor
if you want but it's got to be right up
there you know how emotionally literate
are these people
how emotionally articulate how
emotionally cognizant are they you know
in self-literacy self-awareness is
number one and if that is not placed as
number one in our school curriculums in
our relationship curriculums in our
parenting curriculums we're doomed like
then that's why we are doomed because
self-awareness is nowhere in our
educational curriculum
it's nowhere in the parenting paradigm
and it's not there in the relationship
paradigm we go into these dynamics
of relationships and parenting expecting
the other
to meet our needs
and the other never ever really can ever
fulfill our needs completely or
long-lastingly or consistently
because the other person is deeply
flawed
and so we are really in relationships
with ourselves and others that are
deeply flawed but we go in with such
high expectations that the other will
meet our needs because we're special
and i tell people all the time you're
not special you're unique
you ain't special sweetheart you know
and to the universe you're just the
speck of of a speck of a speck of dust
so
the reason we take it all personally is
because we have expectations these
grandiose fantasies that the other is
meant to complete us the other is meant
to fix us the other is meant to mommy
and daddy us
and the other is a deeply flawed child
looking for you to do the same thing so
now we're competing you know how do but
how do we find that awareness by
putting self-awareness as a top priority
in your own life what does that look
like it's therapy
taking courses
uh meditating
that part of our life has been so denied
by culture because it's not about being
rich it's not about being successful
it's not about getting a trophy or a
prize it's not about being skinny so
that part is a private part it's it's
entering solitude it's sitting and
meditating every day it's writing in a
journal it's talking to a therapist
is taking a course it's very unglamorous
and unromantic
and it's something you do because you
want to have a deeper connection with
yourself
but we've been trained to not have deep
connections with ourselves we've been
trained to have deep connections with
the external world
this is the fundamental sickness of our
world as we've been trained to look
outward
to look outside like the children are
more important the husband is more
important the partner is more important
the lover is more important the what
other people think is more important and
we've lost connection with ourselves but
in essence
our relationship with ourselves needs to
be number one now people will say
especially women that that's so selfish
it's not selfish because when you have a
flourishing relationship with yourself
you need other people less
and because you need them less you suck
on them less
and because you suck on them less you're
less angry with them so they're actually
better
off when you when you focus on yourself
you know
and uh people don't realize that because
again our eyes are conditioned to look
outward so that's why eastern
mindfulness in my life has been the key